madame la Présidente chers collègues la
commission des affaires économiques a
mené depuis mi-septembre un important
cycle d'audition sur les questions
énergétiques qui nous a permis
d'entendre les ministres compétents les
industriels des universitaires des
responsables d'EDF entreprises chargée
de la production électrique ou encore le
président de RTE le réseau de transport
de l'électricité il manquait à
l'évidence une audition portant sur la
distribution de l'électricité et cette
lacune est aujourd'hui réparée nous
recevons donc ce soir Madame Marianne
Laigneau présidente du directeur
d'enedis et Nice est une société anonyme
qui constitue le principal gestionnaire
du réseau public de distribution
d'électricité de France elle gère le
réseau basse et moyenne tension sur 95%
du territoire et emploie plus de 38
000 salariés comme le souligner
lucrémont probable futur PDG d'EDF lors
de son audition par notre commission de
26 octobre je cite enedis est un élément
clé du groupe EDF parce que son activité
est la plus proche du terrain je
souhaite d'ailleurs profiter de cette
introduction pour rendre hommage aux
femmes aux hommes de votre entreprise
qui se mobilisent pleinement au
quotidien et dans l'action est
essentielle pour établir le courant
après des aléas climatiques comme les
producteurs et les transporteurs et
mesdistes doit relever les défis de la
transition énergétique il vous faut
accompagner les nouveaux besoins
énergétiques des Français et des
territoires le développement de
l'autoconsommation la multiplication des
objets connectés et particulièrement la
révolution du véhicule électrique qui
vous amène à préparer le réseau de
distribution pour lui permettre
d'accueillir 15 millions de véhicules
électriques d'ici 2035 il faut également
contribuer à la sobriété énergétique
notamment cet hiver ou des tensions
pourraient se produire en cas de grand
froid votre intervention en ce domaine
suscite des interrogations je ne parle
pas ici des ignorants qui confondent
l'enclenchement automatique de la
chauffe du ballon d'eau chaude durant la
nuit entre le 15 octobre 2022 au 15
avril 2023 avec des coupures
d'électricité ce sont souvent les mêmes
qui déversaient de fausses informations
sur le compteur Linky je parle plutôt
des interrogations sur votre capacité à
effectuer des interruptions ciblées qui
de perturberaient pas par exemple les
services de communication pourriez-vous
nous apporter des précisions sur ce
point madame la Présidente vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés merci pour
l'invitation qui m'est faite de parler
cet après-midi de vous un grand plaisir
pour ma part d'échanger avec vous dans
un moment où vous le savez les enjeux
relatifs au secteur de l'énergie sont à
la fois nombreux et complexes et le cœur
du travail de votre commission ce sont
des enjeux de court terme des priorités
immédiates vous en avez certes cité
certaines elles doivent se combiner avec
une nécessaire vision qui doit guider
des choix de long terme donc vous l'avez
rappelé pour appréhender l'ensemble de
ces questions et les indispensables de
regarder l'intégralité de la chaîne de
valeur de l'électricité depuis les
producteurs
jusqu'aux clients finaux et bien sûr le
réseau de distribution d'électricité par
ses missions par son organisation et
l'un des acteurs majeurs de ce secteur
alors vous le savez ce réseau appartient
aux collectivités locales enedis on est
l'opérateur l'investisseur le
gestionnaire le développeur sur 95% du
territoire quelques chiffres avant de
commencer il s'agit du plus grand réseau
européen qui est représente 1,4 millions
de km de lignes soit 35 fois le tour de
la terre chaque année nous construisons
15000 km de raisonnable sur la zone que
nous gérons les français bénéficient
aujourd'hui d'un réseau de distribution
qui est disponible
99,99% du temps vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le Président grâce à
l'engagement au quotidien des 38 000
hommes et femmes d'enedis qui
travaillent sur l'ensemble du territoire
français et sont répartis sur près de
806 notre pays dispose ainsi d'une
infrastructure essentielle performante
en laquelle il peut avoir confiance à la
fois pour assurer des besoins
d'acheminement en électricité partout et
pour tous j'y reviendrai mais aussi pour
conduire des grandes transformations
nécessaires à la teinte de la neutralité
carbone donc je voudrais dans le temps
qui m'est donné vous faire partager à la
fois les enjeux qui sont les nôtres les
principaux et bien sûr les atouts dont
nous disposons pour les relevés alors
quels sont quels sont ces enjeux 50
enjeux principaux de manière rapide le
premier bien sûr celui qui préoccupe
tous nos concitoyens c'est la maîtrise
des prix de l'énergie pour eux pour les
collectivités locales pour nos
entreprises avec des prix qui ont
atteint des pics incroyables cet été en
prix de mégawattheure par Euro une
hausse donc brutale et de grande ampleur
qui suscitent beaucoup de difficultés
est-ce que le réseau public de
distribution peut contribuer à sa
manière à la maîtrise de ses prix dans
une facture d'électricité le tarif
d'acheminement qu'on appelle le Turc
représente un peu moins d'un tiers de la
facture d'électricité la part dite
énergie pour un tiers et les taxes
pèsent pour on va dire le dernier gros
tiers le Turp n'a donc aucun impact sur
les prix de marché de l'électricité ces
dernières reflètes uniquement le coût de
la fourniture d'énergie mais nous sommes
une entreprise de services publics donc
au service de nos clients qui sont les
Français et nous faisons donc tous nos
efforts possibles
pour dégager de la performance et de la
productivité afin de limiter l'impact
sur la facture de nos clients à cet
égard Linky permet par une meilleure
connaissance des usages de consommation
mais aussi par leur capacité combinées à
des éco-gestes permet de réaliser des
économies sur cette facture
d'électricité qui sont estimées jusqu'à
12% par l'adepte deuxième enjeu c'est la
fin programmée des combustibles fossiles
électricité elle représente aujourd'hui
25% de la consommation finale d'énergie
c'est la situation en 2022 elle est
amenée à représenter suivant les
scénarios le scénario RTE comprend entre
55 et 60% de notre consommation finale
d'énergie en 2050 donc nous allons faire
x 2 en consommation
d'électricité en même temps que nous
allons nous la collectivité nationale
déployée d'intenses effort énergétique
donc au globale baisser la consommation
d'énergie mais l'électricité va
augmenter cette électricité décarbonée
que nous acheminons à la vocation à se
substituer aux énergies fossiles partout
où nous pouvons électrifier les usages
dans les transports dans les bâtiments
dans le chauffage il y a par exemple 3
millions de chaudières fuel à remplacer
dans les 10 ans qui viennent dont un
million par des pompes à chaleur ce
seront des pompes à chaleur raccordés au
réseau public de distribution deuxième
illustration pour la première fois les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
seront exclusivement alimentés par le
réseau public de distribution pour
l'ensemble des usages de l'électricité
cela implique qu'aucun groupe
électrogène fuel ne fut souviendra
pendant cet événement ce qui constituera
un changement majeur pour le secteur de
l'événementiel et une économie de 4
millions et quelques de litres de diesel
par rapport aux JO de Londres en en 2012
dernier exemple
nous opérons aujourd'hui
une activité que nous n'aurions
peut-être pas imaginé nous voir demander
il y a 5 ans c'est l'électrification des
quais des ports français dans le cadre
du projet 0 escale il nous est demandé
d'amener l'électricité jusqu'au quai de
stationnement des gros bateaux de
croisière ou de ferry qui lorsqu'ils
sont hackés pour avoir de l'électricité
pour leurs usages sont obligés de faire
tourner des moteurs diesel ce qui
entraîne de la pollution de la fumée et
donc beaucoup de nuisances
environnementale en particulier pour les
habitants et bien nous amenons
maintenant l'électricité pour raccorder
au réseau de distribution ces navires et
en 20 minutes vous raccordez un navire
comme vous raccorder aujourd'hui une
voiture électrique on économise ainsi
les émissions de 10 à 30 000 véhicules
l'équiv de 10 à 30 000 véhicules
thermiques et les pollutions associées
donc vous le voyez plus électricité
c'est plus de réseau c'est plus d'usage
de l'électricité et c'est ça qui guide
notre feuille de route le troisième
enjeu qui vous occupe
qui vous occupera très bientôt c'est le
développement et l'accueil des énergies
nouvelles renouvelables sur le réseau de
distribution plus de plus d'électricité
c'est aussi beaucoup plus
d'énergie renouvelables aujourd'hui ces
énergies renouvelables solaires éolien
en dehors des très grandes installations
et en particulier de l'éolien en mer qui
est raccordé directement sur le réseau
de transport donc chez nos collègues de
RTE tout le reste environ 90% de la
production renouvelable française et
raccordée au réseau de distribution
publique
cela représente aujourd'hui 600
000 sites de production renouvelables
réparties sur tout le territoire
ce sont des efforts de raccordement
extrêmement important pour l'entreprise
inédits un chiffre qui peut être cité en
2018 nous avions établi un record nous
avions un raccordé 2,5 GW de NR en 2021
nous avons battu ce record avec 3,7
gigawatts de NR raccordé mais nous
n'allons pas nous arrêter là puisque
pour respecter la trajectoire de la PPE
il nous faudra passer de 600 000 sites
de production renouvelables à 1 à 2
millions de sites en fonction de la
taille des projets dans les trois quatre
années qui viennent ce développement il
offre il ouvre un nouveau défi qui est
celui du pilotage de la production et de
la consommation sur le réseau de
distribution parce que ce réseau il
continue bien sûr assumer sa mission
j'ai envie de dire historique distribuer
amener l'électricité
au consommateur mais il doit désormais
aussi collecter cette électricité à
partir de ces sites de production et
donc il vit en fait une triple
Révolution il s'était un la chaîne de
valeur elle portait d'unité de
production de grande taille des
centrales nucléaires hydrauliques
thermiques et nous descendions après le
transport électricité jusqu'au client
final donc c'était un fonctionnement
dans un seul sens à partir d'unité
centralisée sur un réseau physique la
triple révolution c'est que ce
fonctionnement est maintenant
bidirectionnel puisque ces sites
injectent et soutir sur le réseau
le réseau bien sûr toujours physique
mais il est de plus en plus digital donc
en fait il est doublé d'un réseau
complètement
diminuérique et enfin ce ne sont plus
que des installations centralisées elles
sont aussi décentralisées
cela nécessite de piloter le réseau
électrique de manière de plus en plus
fine grâce à des objets connectés comme
Linky mais aussi comme nos postes de
distribution Smart à partir de beaucoup
également d'intelligence artificielle
alors est-ce qu'on peut faire plus vite
et plus pour ce raccordement d'énergie
renouvelable dans quelques jours vous
allez engager l'examen après le Sénat du
projet de loi dit accélération de la
production ENR nous sommes bien sûr du
côté d'enedis extrêmement favorable à
toutes les mesures qui vont permettre
d'accélérer de simplifier d'anticiper
notre activité de raccordement il faudra
simplement veiller à ce que des délais
impératifs qui pourraient être fixés
soit cohérent avec ce qu'il est possible
de réaliser en termes de matériel par
exemple puisque vous le savez il y a des
difficultés comme de nombreux secteurs
industriels en termes
d'approvisionnement en matériel
également compatible avec les
responsabilités d'acteurs qui
interviennent sur de la chaîne de ces
raccordements il n'y a pas Kennedy mais
nous sommes bien sûr à la disposition
des rapporteurs des députés des
administrateurs pour en discuter
quatrième enjeu la mobilité électrique
les irve qui sont associés là aussi une
évolution incroyablement ambitieuse nous
comptons aujourd'hui en France un parc
de véhicules tout électrique ou hybride
autour d'un million d'unité il s'agit de
passer à 17 millions d'ici 2035 et vous
le savez Marc le ban l'interdiction des
véhicules thermiques donc là nous
parlons d'un véritable plan Marshall de
la mobilité électrique nous sommes
amenés à mettre en œuvre du côté
d'enedis ça sera plus de 25000
installations de recharge de véhicules
électriques y compris dans le collectif
résidentiel et 400 000 branchements par
an aux alentours de 2030 puisque cette
activité doit commencer à vraiment
décoller à partir de 2025 2026 en termes
d'investissement alors aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation 90% des Français
qui achètent une voiture électrique ont
une maison pourquoi parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils vont
pouvoir
facilement brancher leur voiture et nous
avons fait des études et une très très
grande majorité des clients qui ont
acheté une voiture à électrique n'ont
pas demandé de modification de puissance
ça veut dire que ils ont acheté une
prise renforcée et ils se chargent la
nuit dans leur garage ou devant chez eux
à vitesse lente
la difficulté elle est pour les clients
de ces véhicules électriques qui
habitent en résidentiel collectif
puisque aujourd'hui seul et près de la
moitié des Français habitent dans de
l'habitat collectif qui soit privé ou
qui soit social seulement 2% des 180 000
copropriétés qui ont des places de
parking supérieur à 10 places seulement
2% d'entre elles sont dotés
d'infrastructures de recharge mais
depuis peu le législateur pour accélérer
l'équipement du résidentiel collectif a
permis à inédit de développer une
solution qui est en fait le prolongement
du réseau public de distribution dans
ces parkings qui permet de les équiper
en pré-finançant les travaux de
raccordement puisque pour les
copropriétés c'est souvent le sujet
c'était qui paye l'installation est-ce
que c'est le premier qui lève le doigt
est-ce que la copropriété a envie de
financer même si elle compte des
copropriétaires qui ne sont pas envie de
s'équiper et bien cela permet de
pré-financer les travaux de récordement
et d'être remboursé au fur et à mesure
que des clients vont venir demander des
installations de points de recherche
donc c'est réellement une solution du
réseau public de distribution nous
équipons aussi les aires autoroutières
il y a près de 400 r autoroutières 330
sont déjà équipés alors cette fois-ci de
bornes rapides puisque c'est ça qui
était tendu attendu sur les autoroutes
cinquième enjeu l'aggravation des
risques climatiques l'été on a donné une
illustration bien sûr nous avons élaboré
et depuis toujours des plans de
résilience notamment pour faire face aux
aléas climatiques vous avez cité
monsieur le Président l'engagement
inébranlable des équipes d'enedis pour
dépanner les clients surtout points du
territoire dans des cas de tempête de
coup de vent ou d'inondation mais nous
nous préparons à gérer l'aggravation des
risques climatiques et des événements
qui seront de plus en plus extrêmes cela
implique
de changer des portions de réseau de le
renforcer de le doubler de l'enfouir
d'éliminer les plus anciens de nos
câbles qui peuvent être vecteurs
d'incident
à très court terme je sais que vous êtes
légitimité légitimement vous l'avez
indiqué et préoccupé par la question du
passage de l'hiver je répondrai bien sûr
à toutes les questions que vous aurez
sur ce sujet d'actualité immédiat donc
de grands enjeux des tendances
identifiées à l'horizon 2050 et des
atouts je l'espère pour y répondre alors
la première le premier atout j'aimerais
le dire avec beaucoup de force et de
solennité c'est la force de notre modèle
non pas à celui d'enedis mais celui que
la France a choisi d'avoir un grand
opère opérateur industriel nous sommes
une entreprise industrielle deux
services publics national cette
organisation nationale elle permet des
effets d'échelle d'optimisation en
particulier pour mutualiser les coûts de
développement des réseaux entre les
territoires ou pour assurer en cas de
crise une mobilisation solidaire de
salariés venus de la France entière ou
pour industrialiser des innovations
cette organisation elle garantie la
solidarité entre les territoires grâce à
la péréquation tarifaire mécanisme de
redistribution qui vise à réduire les
écarts économiques entre les territoires
ou les inégalités entre les
consommateurs et les usagers veillons je
le dis d'une manière un peu solennelle à
ce que ce principe ne soit pas affaibli
par des dispositions qui seraient
favorables au développement des réseaux
privés des initiatives sont prises
actuellement en ce sens il faut bien en
mesurer toutes les conséquences sur la
solidarité territoriale que garantit
l'organisation actuelle enfin et vous
avez cité les propos de lucrètement lors
de son audition et les 10 et l'un des
services publics les plus maillés et les
plus proches du territoire nous venons
de renouveler pour une durée de 30 ans
en moyenne 95% de nos contrats de
concession avec nos collectivités tous
les mers disposent d'un interlocuteur
privilégié y compris dans la c'est un
choix de proximité dont nous sommes
fiers et auxquels je suis
personnellement très attaché et donc une
grande conviction que cette organisation
très locale et très nationale à la fois
est un atout pour répondre à ses défis
de planification et de politique
énergétique le deuxième atout c'est la
trajectoire d'investissement et notre
capacité à la tenir dans la durée nous
allons vous l'avez compris pour faire
face à tous les défis que j'ai cités
massivement investir sur le réseau à la
fois pour préparer la transition
écologique et pour augmenter la
résilience de ce réseau face aux aléas
climatiques je vous ai dit que nous
opérions un réseau qui représente 35
fois le tour de la terre tous les quatre
ans
nous construisons un nouveau tour de
terre pour les nouveaux usages de
l'électricité et nous rénovons nous
modernisons nous changeons un tour de
terre
selon l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie lorsque un acteur investit 1
euro dans des énergies renouvelables il
doit aussi investir un à trois euros
dans le réseau pour rendre possible leur
intégration donc nous avons devant nous
une trajectoire d'investissement à 2040
qui s'élève à 96 milliards d'euros ce
qui nous fera passer d'une moyenne de 4
milliards annuels d'investissements en
euros par an ce qui est notre chiffre
par exemple en 2022 nous allons terminer
à environ 4,4 milliards a durablement
plus de 5 milliards et ces
investissements vont irriguer
durablement bien sûr les territoires ne
faisons chaque année 6 milliards d'achat
en France
90% pour des
entreprises françaises sur nos 3
milliards d'achats de travaux 50% se
font via des TPE AMP PME il y a par
exemple plus de l'entreprise d'élagage
en France nous avons 30 8000 salariés en
propres mais nous maintenant aussi 56
000 emplois indirects troisième à tous
et la capacité d'adaptation et
d'innovation aujourd'hui ne foyers sur
10 sont équipés de Linky je pense que
cette un atout essentiel pour la qualité
de service bien sûr vu du client ça
permet des interventions à distance
quand vous voulez augmenter votre
puissance quand vous déménagez plus
personne ne se déplace s'est fait à
distance immédiatement vous avez des
factures sur relever réel et non pas sur
index estimé également vu du réseau
puisque nous pouvons nous transformer de
plus en plus en gestionnaire d'un
système de distribution qui va gérer un
équilibre entre l'offre et la demande au
niveau local avec je l'ai dit de plus en
plus de production intermittentes et
c'est équilibres sont permis aussi par
le pilotage des données je citerai trois
illustrations concrètes le développement
de l'auto-consommation collective que
nous accompagnons et aujourd'hui à peu
près 120 projets de consommation
collective partout en France
ces données permettent de flécher la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments et
permettre de dire une collectivité
regardez tel lycée il consomme de
manière aberrante par rapport à tel
lycée de la même région même population
même sociologie même condition de
température donc concentrez votre
opération de rénovation thermique sur ce
bâtiment elle permet aussi de faire des
économies dans la gestion de l'éclairage
public ce sont quelques exemples et je
pense que nous sommes au début de cette
rénovation de cette révolution du
rapport de chacun à la gestion de
l'électricité qu'il consomme et qu'il va
produire de plus en plus cette capacité
d'innovation et j'en finirée par là elle
a été reconnue au niveau mondial puisque
nous avons été reconnus comme le numéro
1 mondial des opérateurs intelligents de
réseau parmi les 80 distributeurs
mondiaux il s'agissent d'Européens
d'Américains ou d'asiatiques c'est bien
sûr la reconnaissance du savoir-faire
d'enedis mais aussi toute la filière
industrielle avec laquelle nous
travaillons donc du savoir-faire
français je conclus en vous disant que
le réseau de distribution inscrit son
développement dans ses perspectives de
long terme en même temps qu'il gère des
enjeux de très court terme comme le
passage de l'hiver on y reviendra et que
cela nécessite
de rester une entreprise de services
publics une entreprise de services
publics national et local avec des
investissements en croissance et donc
dans un cadre régulatoire qui est fixé
par la creux qui soit stable et
incitatif à l'investissement avec un
actionnaire aligné sur cette vision
industrielle de long terme et qui
suivent ces enjeux et donc vous aurez
dans votre agenda des mois qui viennent
beaucoup de rendez-vous le projet de loi
le projet France nation vers le projet
de loi programmation énergétique la
future PPE qui nous donneront l'occasion
de continuer à échanger et vous pouvez
compter sur ma mobilisation ma
disponibilité et celle de l'ensemble des
équipes d'enedis pour échanger avec vous
sur ces problématiques dont on parle
moins souvent que celle de la production
mais j'espère vous avoir fait partager
ma conviction qui sont tout aussi
essentielles
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente ce
que je vous propose c'est de passer aux
orateurs de groupe madame la Présidente
le principe est simple c'est 4 minutes
par orateur de groupe inclut votre
réponse donc dans dans certains cas les
orateurs peuvent décider de faire des
questions très courtes et attendre des
réponses très courtes de votre part ils
peuvent aussi décider de faire deux
minutes et de laisser 2 minutes ils
peuvent aller jusqu'à un maximum 3
minutes et vous laissez qu'une minute de
réponse je vous propose de commencer
tout de suite avec notre premier
oratrice de groupe mode Brejon comprenez
sens merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la présidente du directoire
d'enedis vous avez cité un certain
nombre d'enjeux je voudrais vous
interroger sur trois d'entre eux le
premier c'est le passage de l'hiver de
l'hiver qui arrive 2022 2023
concernant les traitements ciblés via
Linky qui potentiellement peut être une
alternative au délestage puisque plutôt
que délester ça permet de baisser la
puissance
contractuelle de Linky et donc de garder
quelques usages au lieu de tout couper
est-ce que vous avez prévu de travailler
dessus et si vous est-ce que vous en
êtes le deuxième le jeu plutôt moyen
long terme concerne le réseau en 2020
vous avez évoqué une somme de 69
milliards d'euros nécessaires pour le
réseau en 16 ans comment est-ce que
cette somme se découpe et est-ce que
vous maintenez cette cette projection et
une troisième question sur les délais de
raccordement notamment pour les petites
installations type PV agricoles et
notamment sur tout ce qui va arriver
suite à la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables on va avoir pas mal de
petites installations liées au solaire
comment est-ce que vous comptez
améliorer les délais de raccordement
dans les mois et les années à venir je
vous remercie
de l'hiver donc je reviendrai sans doute
sur d'autres dispositions mais votre
question est très précise c'est est-il
intéressant d'utiliser Linky pour
baisser la puissance d'un client qui
aurait par exemple un abonnement de neuf
kilos à 6 ou de 6 à 3 pour lui permettre
de garder des
usages d'électricité
ce que nous cherchons et à éviter
d'abord c'est d'éviter ses coupures
temporaires et et tournante de deux
heures maximum et donc il y a énormément
de leviers actionnés avant avant d'en
arriver éventuellement à cette solution
mais nous nous y préparons il s'agit là
de passer des pics de consommation qui
sont des pics du matin
et des pics du soir la difficulté si on
d'utiliser des leviers certains comme le
fameux la fameuse neutralisation de
l'enclenchement des ballons d'eau chaude
sur leur creuse méridienne que le
président a rappelé qui rapporte de
manière certaine la consommation d'une
ville comme Paris la difficulté avec la
solution que que vous mentionnez c'est
que on peut avoir un abonnement à 6 kg
mais on ne sait pas ce que le client est
en train réellement de consommer donc au
moment où on doit éviter la coupure où
on doit rééquilibre rééquilibrer l'offre
et la demande si on baisse tout le monde
mais qu'en fait on ne savait pas combien
est consommé on ne sait pas ce qu'on
gagne et donc on peut se trouver dans
une situation très très difficile donc
nous n'envisageons pas à terme nous
prenons préférons utiliser des leviers
qui sont certains dans ce qu'ils vont
permettre de rapporter de gagner
d'économiser au moment où le
déséquilibre ponctuel va se faire
deuxième question c'est le 69 milliards
le 69 milliards c'était effectivement le
chiffre précédent de la distribution
jusqu'à d'investissement envisager
jusqu'en 2035 le chiffre récent que nous
avons communiqué il va plus loin puisque
nous avons son vers le 2050 de la
neutralité carbone il est donc de 96
milliards jusqu'en 2040 et un des
événements nouveaux qui étaient moins
visibles peut-être il y a trois quatre
ans c'est le développement massif du
véhicule électrique et les
investissements que cela supporte
suppose et donc
ces masses sont répartis autour
d'enjeux de développement des
raccordements en particulier de la
mobilité électrique par exemple sur les
96 milliards il y en a 7 milliards et
demi mais d'ici 2040 qui sont consacrés
au sujet de la mobilité électrique et
puis l'autre grande partie c'est
évidemment d'augmenter la résilience des
réseaux et de faire des investissements
d'enfouissement
quelque part d'extension de la durée de
vie pour utiliser vocabulaire d'un autre
secteur très bien merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente Monsieur maisonnet RN
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente je vous remercie pour votre
présence au sein de notre assemblée pour
votre propos luminaire comme vous le
savez les prix de l'électricité s'envole
les restrictions se multiplient les
Français ont le sentiment à juste titre
d'être les victimes de mauvaises
décisions de la responsable politique
l'accès à une électricité abondante bas
carbone peu cher et sûr était l'un de
nos principaux avantages compétitifs
notamment d'un point de vue industriel
nous sommes en train de le perdre cette
situation catastrophique n'est pas une
résultante de la guerre en Ukraine et de
la crise inflationniste elle est surtout
due à des manquements graves et aux
erreurs de politiques qui pendant des
années ont préféré l'idéologie au
pragmatisme le renouvelable est poussé à
un développement anarchique tandis que
notre secteur nucléaire a été fortement
délaissé
nous payons aujourd'hui nous
renoncements d'hier en renonçant à
investir dans de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires et en délaissant l'entretien
de nos infrastructures les différents
gouvernements ont mis en place les
conditions déplorables qui sont
actuellement celles de notre réseau
électrique
aujourd'hui les efforts parfois
grotesques sont demandés aux Français
ces derniers sont prêts à changer leurs
habitudes pour l'intérêt général mais
comment expliquer qu'on leur demande
d'éteindre leur machine à laver qu'on
interdise les terrasses chauffées quand
Bruxelles s'apprête à interdire les
voitures thermiques pour aller vers le
tout électrique à l'horizon 2035 vous
l'avez rappelé faisant ainsi exploser
notre consommation d'électricité
aujourd'hui le gouvernement prétend
vouloir réindustrialiser la France mais
comment le faire si la demande continue
de croître et que la production ne suit
pas les français payent aujourd'hui le
manque d'anticipation et de vision sur
le long terme des dernières décennies je
sais bien que tous ces facteurs ne
dépendent pas d'enedis cependant vous
êtes l'une des personnes les plus
placées pour évaluer l'avenir de notre
parc électrique ma question est donc la
suivante pensez-vous que cette fois les
différents acteurs de l'électricité ont
pris conscience du défi qui les
attendaient ou au contraire devons-nous
désormais nous dire que l'abondance en
électricité c'est terminé au risque
notamment de notre industrie pour suivre
son effondrement je vous remercie
merci Monsieur maisonnet madame la
Présidente
pour cette question dont vous avez
rappelé en la posant qu'elle s'adressait
aussi à d'autres acteurs que le réseau
public de distribution donc simplement
j'ai noté que vous avez indiqué que le
réseau électrique était dans un état
déplorable ça n'est pas le cas j'espère
vous avoir rassuré sur sur ce point il
est dans un état de très haute qualité
et remplie ses missions particuliers en
termes de continuité d'alimentation et
nous faisons tout pour renforcer à la
fois sa résilience et sa performance au
service de nos clients donc pour la
partie qui est ma responsabilité et
malheureusement moi je suis juste
l'entreprise qui opère le réseau public
de distribution au bénéfice d'ailleurs
de tous les fournisseurs puisque nous
avons ces missions de service public et
tous les fournisseurs sont nos clients
simplement j'ai l'impression pour
répondre de manière un peu un peu
générale à votre question que la
conscience autour de l'importance des
questions d'énergie dans l'économie
française dans la souveraineté française
également dans l'indépendance
énergétique du pays sont peut-être plus
importantes aujourd'hui en tout cas
parmi nos concitoyens à quelle de l'été
hier peut-être peut le regretter que ce
soit sous l'effet de facteurs négatifs
mais ces sujets sont à la fois
géostratégiques mais ils sont aussi et
j'espère vous l'avoir fait partager très
concret l'électricité que nous
acheminons c'est la vie quotidienne des
Français c'est leur confort c'est le
développement économique des territoires
c'est de l'emploi c'est de la formation
professionnelle c'est de l'insertion
c'est de l'apprentissage voilà donc nous
sommes très mobilisés sur sur ces
missions qui s'exerce effectivement dans
un cadre qui aujourd'hui est complexe et
chahuté merci beaucoup monsieur l'aîné
LFI
ça y est merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente enedis a été créé
pour répondre aux injonctions
européennes de découpage de l'entreprise
historique pour faciliter la
libéralisation du marché de l'énergie on
voit pourtant que celui-ci aujourd'hui
est incapable de répondre aux enjeux
d'approvisionnement il manque un outil
de planification stratégique qui
garantissent une plaine et entière
maîtrise publique sur ces enjeux de la
production jusqu'à la fourniture
d'électricité ne pensez-vous pas alors
que l'État a fait le choix de
recapitaliser EDF à 100%, qu'il
conviendrait d'aller plus loin en
modifiant les statuts d'EDF enedis et de
RTE pour revenir vers une forme plus
intégrée sous la forme d'un
établissement public afin de répondre
aux enjeux de service public mais aussi
pour écarter le risque d'un retour d'un
projet de type Hercule notre collègue
socialiste Philippe Brun à usé de son
droit récemment et est tombé sur des
documents qui nous inquiètent au plus
haut point un monopole public ne
serait-il pas plus efficace de manière
plus factuelle comment envisagez-vous
votre rôle auprès des collectivités pour
éviter les risques réels de cet hiver
d'autant que le redémarrage des
centrales semble compromis comme la
presse en effet l'écho ces derniers
jours je parle des centrales nucléaires
évidemment vous indiquez dans un article
des échos du mois dernier que les
coupures que vous seriez obligés de
mettre en œuvre à la demande de RTE se
limiterait à deux heures et passerait
par la coupure de certains départs de
ligne moyenne tension alimentant environ
200000 personnes cette approche remet
clairement en cause le principe de
continuité du service public en tout cas
c'est notre avis une approche qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'aveugle alors que
les enjeux de sobriété doivent prendre
en compte l'idée d'une responsabilité
différenciée d'après nous auriez-vous
d'autres solutions pour prévenir ces
coupures et comment êtes-vous associé à
la définition de ces stratégies
notamment enedis travaille sur la
question des éclairages publics qui
représentent 40% de la consommation des
collectivités ne pensez-vous pas que le
gouvernement doit légiférer pour
transformer les incitations de couper
l'éclairage de nuit en véritable
obligation pour les collectivités mais
aussi pour les grandes enseignes
alors que nous allons vers une vers une
nécessaire électrification des usages
vous en avez parlé dans votre propre
éliminaire et un développement de la
voiture électrique en particulier
pensez-vous possible de tenir l'agenda
de développement des bornes électriques
publiques et des raccordements à
domicile vous avez déjà en partie
répondu enfin alors que la loi sur les
énergies renouvelables est actuellement
en discussion comment avoir abordez-vous
les enjeux de développement des
capacités de distribution quels sont les
principales difficultés à surmonter qui
permettraient d'aller vers le scénario
de 100% renouvelable proposé à la fois
par RTE par l'ADEME et negawat et que
nous faisons notre au groupe LFI UPS
dernière chose disposez-vous aujourd’hui
des ressources et des moyens humains
pour se faire développer leur
renouvelables alors même que vous êtes
déjà si nos informations sont correctes
en sous-effectif chronique
merci la présidente
je commencerai par le sujet des coupures
effectivement ce que nous cherchons à
développer c'est d'abord tous les autres
leviers qui nous permettent d'éviter
cette solution extrême quelles sont ses
autres leviers ce sont d'abord des
leviers de sobriété donc nous avons
beaucoup communiqué autour des usages de
ce que permet de faire les Linky alors
au-delà de ce que Madame régent a évoqué
tout à l'heure mais ce qu'on peut faire
avec Linky pour à la fois connaître sa
consommation en consultant notamment
l'application enedis à mes côtés qui est
très facile d'usage mais il y a celle
aussi des fournisseurs et en pilote en
mieux chez soi
ces appareils électriques sur le réseau
il y a d'autres leviers que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre c'est la baisse de
tension puisque cela permettra une
baisse de tension de 5%
d'économiser là aussi autour de 3 à 4
gigawatts donc suivant le nombre de
gigawatts qui nous manqueront et cela on
l'a testé et on le mettra en oeuvre avec
RTE c'est la solution déclenchement des
ballons d'eau chaude dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure qui rapporte entre
guillemets elle aussi de gigawatts et
demi à l'heure de la pose méridienne et
puis ce sont d'autres solutions de
sobriété vous les avez évoquées pour les
collectivités locales le pilotage de
l'éclairage public alors je voudrais
vous dire que nous ne sommes pas en
sous-effectif nous recrutons nous
formons et au contraire nous avons
augmenté nos effectifs pour faire face à
l'ensemble de ces enjeux merci beaucoup
j'ai madame dubitmüller LR
madame la Présidente merci pour la
présentation de vos atouts et la
stratégie de nedis en tant qu'élu d'un
département de montagne je souhaite
appeler votre attention sur les
conséquences pour la sécurité de la
population permanente et saisonnière des
zones de montagne une interruption de
l'alimentation électrique des
infrastructures de télécommunications
durant cet hiver dans le cadre du plan
de délestage qui se traduirait par
l'impossibilité temporaire d'acheminer
les appels d'urgence enedis sera-t-il en
capacité technique de protéger cet hiver
de tout délestage électrique les
infrastructures de télécommunication en
montagne qui joue un rôle majeur pour
l'accès des secours ainsi que l'accès
aux services médicaux et d'urgence je
vous remercie
question importante qui m'a été posée
plusieurs fois donc dans les plans
envisagés éventuels de délestage
temporaire par période de deux heures
comme ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure
les coupures ne sont pas via évidemment
pas via le compteur Linky elles se font
directement sur le réseau de
distribution sur ce qu'on appelle les
départs qui alimentent des milliers de
clients suivants suivant suivant sa
configuration
mais il y a aussi des clients dit
prioritaires qui doivent représenter
jusqu'à 38% de la puissance du
département et qui eux seront protégés
épargnés entre guillemets par ces
coupures potentielles parce que ce sont
tout simplement des hôpitaux des sites
de défense des grandes entreprises
indispensables au fonctionnement des
pays du pays ça ça n'est pas enedis qui
est établi cette liste de sites
prioritaires ce sont les préfectures et
nous avons avec les services de
intérieur et énergie énormément
travaillé avec les préfets pour les
aider à établir ces listes mais elles
sont maintenant établies et les arrêter
sont en voie d'être publiées et donc
ces clients dit prioritaires ne seront
pas coupés et d'ailleurs pas non plus
leurs voisins puisqu'ils bénéficieront
quelque part du fait d'être dans une
poche qui comprend un client prioritaire
alors s'agissant des télécoms il y a des
dizaines de milliers d'antenne relais
pour lesquelles les opérateurs de
télécom n'ont pas prévu contrairement à
ce que obligent la continuité de service
public de systèmes de secours et donc
nous avons travaillé avec eux pour
croiser nos listes ces listes de sites
prioritaires et ce qu'ils appellent les
nœuds de leur réseau qui sont les
endroits prioritaires qu'il faut
préserver pour que des situations comme
celles que vous décrivez ne se
produisent pas donc nous sommes très
attentifs à la situation des réseaux
télécommunications avec lesquels nous
avons beaucoup
collaborer
mais tous ne pourront pas être
considérés comme prioritaire pas les
dizaines de milliers d'antennes que
compte le pays je rappelle qu'il
s'agirait de coupure d'une durée quand
même autour de deux heures ce qui arrive
assez fréquemment que par exemple quand
vous avez des travaux chez vous dans
votre truc enedis change ou installa un
câble ça arrive d'être coupé quelques
heures je ne dis pas que c'est rien et
donc il faut le préparer de manière très
très sérieuse c'est ce que nous faisons
et en particulier avec les opérateurs de
télécom mais aussi avec l'ensemble des
autres services publics puisqu'il y a
aussi la sécurité civile il y a aussi le
ferroviaire il y a aussi les feux
d'alimentation donc tout ça est pris en
compte sous la responsabilité des
préfets
il reste 30 secondes c'est bon pour vous
très bien merci Monsieur boulot modem
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente et merci d'être présente
pour nous donner l'occasion de parler
des réseaux ce qu'en matière de
d'énergie on parle souvent de la
production et de la consommation et sans
les réseaux il y a pas de distribution
d'électrons les préoccupations vous
l'avez signalé actuellement sont souvent
celles des prix de l'énergie de le
renvoler de l'augmentation
très importante du prix d'électricité
mais à notre sujet qui qui revient
régulièrement il a été évoqué par
plusieurs de mes collègues c'est celui
des coupures hivernales et un certain
nombre de questions nous sont
régulièrement adressés sur le sujet qui
sera concerné avec quel délai de
connaissance les coupures seront-elles
annoncées et pour moi toutes ces
questions relèvent d'une certaine façon
d'un manque de communication autour de
ce sujet de des coupures nécessaires la
résilience de notre réseau et donc
j'aimerais savoir quelques éléments de
d'information complémentaires par
rapport à ce que vous avez déjà dit
notamment par rapport au réseau d'eau
est-ce qu'ils seront eux est-ce qu'ils
sont prioritaires ou non parce que sans
eux il y a aussi quelques activités qui
vont avoir des difficultés notamment les
activités de santé dire un CHU n'ont
coupé c'est une chose mais s'il a pas
d'eau ça va être quand même un peu
problématique et puis j'aimerais savoir
quels sont les mesures que vous pouvez
mettre en place pour faciliter la
communication sur ces coupures parce
qu'il revient aussi à chacun de pouvoir
s'organiser individuellement et pour
pouvoir les préparer le mieux possible
lorsqu'elles surviendrait si cela est le
cas
elle a la présidente merci donc
effectivement
le fait qu'on se dirige vers des
coupures potentielles n'est pas connue
au dernier moment vous savez RTE a mis
en place un système qui s'appelle
Ecowatt et donc et communiquer largement
maintenant quand vous regardez le
bulletin météo sur les chaînes
télévisées le fait que nous soyons dans
une situation éco-wattes facile c'est à
dire verte un peu tendu c'est à dire
orange au rouge éventuellement en cas de
tension et ça veut dire que chacun doit
essayer le plus possible de faire des
efforts pour économiser l'électricité au
moment des pics de consommation c'est à
dire essentiellement le matin et le soir
au fur et à mesure carpe affine à la
fois ça prévisions météorologique parce
qu'on ne prédit pas on prévoit pas la
météo à un mois donc les premières
alertes de situations tendues sont émis
une semaine avant le moment et puis
c'est affiné au fur et à mesure mais il
faut des prévisions météorologiques il
faut le niveau de la production en
France moment considéré et puis la
capacité d'importation ces trois
facteurs sont précisés à J-3 AG J-2 donc
on a prévu d'informer largement
l'ensemble des acteurs concernés bien
sûr les collectivités locales bien sûr
les grandes entreprises de manière
anticipée à partir de J-2 pour leur dire
attention la situation est tendue vous
pourriez faire l'objet d'une coupure
mais ce coupure se font à la demande de
RTE qui envoie c'est un peu technique
des blocs de mégawatts à délester aux
agences de conduite d'enedis il y en a
28 en France ce sont des centres de
pilotage comme les aiguilleurs du ciel
si vous voulez mais de l'électricité qui
vont répartir ces coupures potentielles
sur le territoire pour éviter que ce
soit que des clients soient coupés
plusieurs fois dans la journée donc il
faut que ce soit réparti pour que ce
soit égalitaire d'une certaine manière
et donc l'information elle sort elle
s'affinera de manière de plus en plus
précise nous serons évidemment en lien
avec les préfectures et la veille au
soir vous pourrez en allant sur le site
Ecobat qui en fait va communiquer avec
les sites d'information
enedis et bien rentré votre adresse
précise et savoir si potentiellement
beau ou pas vous faites l'objet d'une
coupure mais bien évidemment nous aurons
une cellule de crise dans chaque
département avec l'ensemble des préfets
et nous informerons les collectivités
locales via toute notre réseau dans leur
interlocuteur privilégié de la situation
potentielle dans laquelle il se met vous
le comprenez c'est quelque chose qui
s'affine jour après jour et heure par
heure merci beaucoup madame batistel
socialiste
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la présidente du directoire de sujets
peut-être oui plus que deux puisque le
premier a été évoqué par ma collègue du
bimmy Miller sur la question
des
télécommunications et du maintien de la
continuité notamment sur les appels de
secours donc vous y avez répondu la
deuxième portée sur
je souhaiterais que vous nous rapportiez
plus précisément les principales
contraintes que vous rencontrez
aujourd'hui en matière de déploiement
des réseaux dans notamment des délais
dans le cadre du développement des EnR
nous avons des textes en cours notamment
celui de l'accélération des ONF nous
portons
en tout cas pour certains une ambition
forte sur le développement des EnR notre
ambition c'est une chose la capacité de
pouvoir suivre en matière de de
développement des réseaux et de
et de confortement des réseaux en est
une autre donc pouvez-vous nous donner
plus précisément le cadre des
contraintes que cela pourrait poser vous
disiez tout à l'heure que 600000 sites
avaient été équipés que vous visez entre
1 et 2 millions de sites
ça fait une augmentation importante
d'infrastructures sur trois ou quatre
ans donc voilà un petit peu le les
éléments et en tout cas peut-être ce
qu'il faudrait qu'on apporte dans le
cadre de cette loi pour aussi sécuriser
cela
ma deuxième question porterait sur le
sujet aussi qui fait un peu l'actualité
actuellement et notamment la question de
mon collègue Philippe Brun à la mini à
la première ministre tout à l'heure
concernant les projets de
restructuration des DF et notamment
Hercule bis qui se profile à l'horizon
dans le projet Hercule numéro 1 et 2
d'ailleurs
il y avez enedis c'était dans le volet
vert ce qui entraînait évidemment un
démantèlement des différentes activités
les projets qui sont sur la table
montrent que on est encore dans ce
schéma là est-ce que vous avez des
informations est-ce que vous avez des
inquiétudes par rapport à cela et
si oui est-ce que vous pouvez nous les
exprimer je vous remercie
de la présidente merci très rapidement
sur sur le raccordement donc nous nous
avons fait des des efforts extrêmement
importants pour réduire les délais de
raccordement en revoyant l'ensemble de
nos processus en renvoyant nos systèmes
d'information en mettant des ressources
supplémentaires et en travaillant
beaucoup avec les fédérations de
producteurs renouvelables pour ce qui
est la partie raccordement des
renouvelables et donc dans le projet de
loi je dirais que un système actuel tout
ce qui permet
d'accélérer de simplifier les
autorisations administratives en
particulier préalable donné par les
préfets sur les projets tout ça va dans
le bon sens donc nous nous sommes
favorables à tout le paquet de mesures
qui est déjà envisagée qui permet
d'accélérer de et de simplifier après il
y a peut-être une autre question mais
peut-être pour plus tard autour de la
planification énergétique qui
permettrait de mieux se faire rencontrer
les réseaux et les projets des
producteurs j'observe qu'aujourd'hui et
bien beaucoup de projets renouvelables
se développent dans des endroits où il y
a peu d'habitants et donc il n'y avait
pas de consommateurs d'électricité et où
donc le réseau n'était pas énormément
développé ce qui nous a conduit à
annoncer des délais extrêmement longs
RTE et nous à certains producteurs parce
que tout simplement il y a pas de ligne
à haute tension RTE et ça se construit
pas en six mois et il y a pas non plus
de poste source enedis et donc tout ce
qui permettrait de mieux se faire faire
rencontrer les projets de renouvelables
qui sont nécessaires au développement de
ces énergies mais aussi les contraintes
et les réalités du réseau me semblerait
aller dans le bon sens et donc c'est
tout l'espace de la planification je
suis sûr que j'aurai une autre question
sur Hercule bis pour y répondre très
bien monsieur Warsmann horizon
ça n'est pas horizon monsieur le
Président mais je vous en prie ça n'est
pas du tout à reproche madame prison du
rétoire deux choses un témoignage et une
alerte un témoignage d'abord pour vous
féliciter vous servir dans mon
département nous avons depuis 2019
l'ancien est avec le seul gouvernement
un plan de religion vous avez vraiment
des services une réactivité qui se
remette en cause qui se s'adapte qui
sont vraiment remarquables une audition
à l'Assemblée parfois pas agréable pour
une présidente vraiment prenez ce
compliment transmettez-les à vos équipes
parce que c'est vraiment hérité l'alerte
que j'ai c'est dans le sud de ce que
vous venez de dire c'est le schéma
zurlable vous l'avez dit vous le
concertez avec les syndicats énergies
renouvelables donc par exemple sur le
lien vous trouvez des gens qui savent
dire deux ou trois ans avant voilà ce
qu'on va faire
dans mon département on est très actif
par exemple sur rivoltaïsme et vous
services me disent par exemple je vous
cite un exemple vous y êtes les
transformateurs on est saturés on sera
plus vous dire quoi et on ne saura vous
répondre de quatre que dans 4 ou 5 ans
parce que la production supplémentaire
qui va être diffuse 4 5 mégawatts par
Jupiter qui va faire un projet celle-ci
on ne l'a pas dans notre viseur on
aperçu à prévoir donc la présente je
pense qu'il faut que accroître agilité
et si vous voulez faire des
expérimentations sur un territoire dans
notre pays mon territoire les Ardennes
sont tout à fait prêtes à le faire avec
vous je vous remercie bien Madame la
présence d'une réponse courte un grand
merci d'abord pour les félicitations que
je transmettrai bien sûr aux équipes
d'enedis merci pour ces propos qui nous
vendront au cœur sur votre deuxième
question en réalité les conditions
réglementaires et législatives ont fait
que de ce qui était autrefois de la
responsabilité des petits producteurs
c'est-à-dire de se doter d'un poste de
distribution a été transférée parce que
la loi a rendu beaucoup plus favorable
enfin ce sont des arrêtés le fait d'être
de se mettre à 250 kg et donc de
bénéficier d'absence d'autorisation mais
aussi de l'obligation d'achat les
projets ont été multipliés par 10 les
devis entre octobre de l'année dernière
et mars de cette année multipliée par 10
et de ce fait c'est à enedis
qui est un con maintenant la
responsabilité de fournir ses postes de
distribution que nous commandons par
dizaines de milliers mais de fait il y a
la crise des matériels il y a la crise
d'approvisionnement et nous pouvons
rencontrer c'est réels certaines
difficultés donc ça n'est pas un manque
d'anticipation de notre part monsieur
député c'est un changement de la
réglementation qui a fait passer la
responsabilité d'un acteur à l'autre
nous nous adaptons nous avons signé des
nouveaux marchés bien madame larnus
écologiste
merci
vous l'avez souligné le réseau de
distribution et le rôle des nénisses et
absolument fondamental dans la société
qu'on est en train de construire et dans
l'utilisation notamment et la mise en
place de la planification écologique et
de la transition écologique je voulais
aborder deux sujets principaux les le
premier j'ai envie de dire c'est la
question du modèle vous ayez fait
référence des contrats de concession
avec les collectivités territoriales et
leur renouvellement puisqu'il y a et
dans mes anciennes fonctions des lieux
locales quand même une surprise dans le
fait que les collectivités territoriales
n'ont pas de réels pouvoirs d'action ou
de contrôle sur les investissements qui
sont faits et comment ils sont faits il
y a des comptes rendus annuels de
contrats de concession dans lequel vous
rendez compte des investissements mais
par exemple pour donner un exemple avec
l'établissement et le déploiement du
compteur Linky il y a eu une baisse dans
les investissements dans les réseaux
locaux et puis si on regarde les avec le
renouvellement des réseaux
HTA et BT sont quasi inexistants le
rythme médian est de 520 ans pour le
réseau BT et 427 ans pour le réseau HTA
alors que par l'Allemand il y a plus
d'un milliard d'euros qui part
annuellement à la maison mère la part
des provisions aussi pour renouvellement
mobiliser pour les travaux de
renouvellement et assez faibles autour
de 10% ce qui a des conséquences
patrimoniales importantes notamment sur
le financement des ouvrages et sur le
ticket de sortie et interroge aussi sur
la gestion du stock des provisions pour
renouvellement par le concessionnaire ça
c'était sur la partie vraiment travail
avec les collectivités territoriales sur
le raccordement sur les énergies
renouvelables ensuite puisque j'aimerais
vous reposer la question sur avez-vous
chiffré ce que ça représente pour
l'évolution du réseau enedis le scénario
de RTE et de l'ADEME du 100% énergies
renouvelable on voit aujourd'hui vous
avez évoqué des territoires plus ruraux
dans la métropole dans lequel je vis il
y a là aussi des remontées des communes
qui ne ont des délais dement absolument
délirants sur des projets de
d'installation aux énergies
renouvelables qui sont déjà installés et
une incompréhension forte qui monte dans
le fait qu'il y a des investissements
publics qui ont été faits qu'on parle
d'une crise de l'énergie et que faute de
raccordement on ne peut pas bénéficier
de cette électricité la même chose sur
les projets d'autoconsommation vous avez
évoqué 120 projets en France on nous en
avons mené plusieurs notamment sur la
métropole de Nantes avec là aussi un
travail en commun mais des difficultés
aussi par rapport au raccordement qui
obèrent et qui freinent aussi des
projets qui sont pourtant essentiels sur
le renouvellement sur en tout cas le
développement de des projets
d'autoconsommation qu'ils soient
collectifs publics privés en tout cas
c'est sur ces deux questions et puis il
y aura une question aussi subsidiaire
sur la résilience des réseaux face au
réchauffement climatique merci beaucoup
alors en une minute une réponse à toutes
ces questions
qui concerne la distribution et donc si
on va vers un scénario tous les
scénarios ont beaucoup plus de NR et
donc c'est ça les hypothèses que nous
prenons 100% NR au lieu d'investir 5
milliards par an dans les réseaux de
distribution il faudra investir 8
milliards donc c'est une question pour
la collectivité nationale le dividende
toute entreprise remonte un dividende à
sa maison mère sinon c'est une
administration ce qui n'est pas notre
cas
et troisième question
vous avez évoqué le contrat de
concession que nous venons de renouveler
et je m'en félicite avec la métropole de
Nantes je pense que le compte-rendu
d'activité doit faire quelques centaines
de pages donc il donne beaucoup beaucoup
de détails et c'est normal que nous en
donnons sur notre activité à ce qui est
nos notre concentractant et ça
s'accompagne surtout qu'une convention
de transition écologique qui nous permet
d'avancer ensemble vers cet avenir de la
sobriété et de la neutralité carbone
merci beaucoup monsieur Molac
merci monsieur le Président donc Madame
alors j'avais une question aussi sur le
réseau d'adaptation par rapport aux ovnr
parce qu'effectivement on va développer
en particulier le photovoltaïque dont je
rappelle que le coût est à peu près de
50 à 60 enfin était avant la crise de 50
à 60 euros du mégawatt et l'éolien qui
est à peu près à 70 euros du mégawatt je
dis ça parce que le nucléaire c'est
plutôt à 120 120 euros 140 euros du
mégawatt donc c'est pas forcément le
moyen le plus le meilleur marché pour
pouvoir avoir de l'électricité alors il
a l'avantage lui de ne pas être
intermittent d'accord mais il y a c'est
quand même ça coûte cher il faut le
savoir donc chez nous également on a un
bon réseau avec le syndicat
d'électrification du Morbihan puisque
qui est propriétaire du réseau et donc
ça se passe plutôt bien d'ailleurs je
n'ai pas de personnes qui viennent se
plaindre en ma permanence donc a priori
ça doit bien se passer sinon vous
inquiétez pas ça finirait forcément dans
ma Perm
donc j'ai bien entendu vos réponses moi
aussi je suis assez sensible à cette
organisation de type national je
rappelle quand même que c'est un acquis
poste Seconde Guerre mondiale et que la
péréquation et la solidarité ce sont des
choses qui pour moi veulent dire quelque
chose alors j'aimerais bien que si vous
pouviez nous expliquer et puis mettre
fin à cette polémique comme quoi le
Linky c'est l'opérateur qui vient d'un
regarder ce que font les gens décrocher
tel ou tel appareil etc ce qu'il ne peut
évidemment pas faire on a eu aussi une
polémique sur les chauffe-eau qui avait
un tarif réglementé comme quoi il a été
décidé que ses chauffe-eau chaufferait
plutôt à telle époque à tel autre et ça
y est certains avaient polémiqué en
disant que ça y est c'était je sais pas
Big Brother ou l'État qui venait
directement dans les maisons pour
allumer le chauffe-eau il faudra je
pense tordre le coup à tout ça parce que
c'est un peu pénible et finalement ça
nous aide pas à être efficace lorsque
nous aurons des pointes de consommation
ça rejoint d'ailleurs mon propos
introductif madame la Présidente
merci merci de nouveau pour les
remerciements que vous adressez aux
équipes d'aînésie pour leur travail en
proximité des territoires nous sommes
vraiment là pour être à vos côtés sur le
développement des projets de transition
écologique et à une distance parlons de
la transition écologique notre projet
d'entreprise industrielle et humains et
fondée sur la transition pas seulement
énergétique mais écologique parce que
notre responsabilité elle est plus large
que celle de la seule
électricité et donc oui il y a eu
beaucoup de
polémiques au départ du compteur Linky
dont je voudrais rappeler quand même que
c'est un grand projet industriel qui est
arrivé en temps et en heure puisque nous
avions cinq ans 2016-2021 pour installer
90% des foyers français avec le compteur
Linky et cela a été fait ce n'est pas
peut-être si souvent avec un projet
atterri en temps et en heure et surtout
pour un coup inférieur au budget initial
envisagés alors les polémiques qui
avaient lieu autour de
la maîtrise des données est-ce que Linky
permet de savoir quand chacun prend sa
douche évidemment la réponse est non les
données elles appartiennent aux
consommateurs individuels elles ne sont
communiquées à des fournisseurs par
exemple qu'avec son accord et tout un
système réglementaire extrêmement
encadrés contre les par la CNIL qui
vient souvent nous voir pour vérifier
que tout est bien en place qui garantit
cela vous avez évoqué les derniers
développements j'aimerais dire qu'au
contraire Linky permet parce que
déconnecter le ballon d'eau chaude son
enclenchement entre 12h et 14h ça c'est
possible depuis les années 70 il y a pas
besoin du compteur Linky pour faire ça
ce que permet le compteur Linky à
l'inverse c'est de continuer à
bénéficier des heures creuses
méridiennes pour tous les autres usages
de capacité dans la maison donc je crois
effectivement il faut rétablir comme
vous le faites les vérités de base merci
beaucoup je vais vous proposer de passer
aux questions individuelles nous
commençons par Monsieur Bouix une minute
par question individuelle et vous
répondrez à la toute fin monsieur
le président madame la présidente madame
Laigneau dans le Calvados ça a
Hérouville-Saint-Clair et j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour saluer son maire
Rodolphe Thomas enedis a mis en place un
dispositif d'accompagnement aux
économies d'énergie pour les
propriétaires occupants il s'agit du
dispositif help Renov enedis fournit
ainsi des pistes d'économies pour ses
clients dans un contexte d'incertitude
où chacun cherche des informations pour
s'en sortir au mieux la Normandie région
pilote en France permettra peut-être
avec une généralisation du dispositif
d'aider l'ensemble des Français
pouvez-vous nous expliquer plus en
détail ce dispositif ainsi que les
échéances pour son élargissement merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame trouvé
merci
bonjour donc chers collègues madame la
Présidente donc j'étais ce matin dans ma
circonscription sur le site enedis de
Noisy-le-Sec pour soutenir les salariés
qui sont en grève depuis le 24 octobre
et depuis il y a une cinquantaine comme
vous le savez d'autres sites qui sont
mobilisés et leur demande comme vous
savez c'est une juste revalorisation des
salaires puisque leur salaire n’ont été
augmentés il me semble que de 2,3% cette
année il demande une augmentation
supplémentaire de 5% comme dans bien
d'autres entreprises et notamment la
maison mère EDF ce qui permettrait à
peine que les salaires suivent
l'augmentation des prix depuis deux ans
en somme de demande qu'un maintien de
leur salaire réel donc ma question est
la seule celle-ci aujourd'hui
puisqu'il me semble que vous étiez en
négociation avec eux qu'en est-il de
cette demande d'augmentation des
salaires il y aura-t-il un maintien du
salaire réel comme il le demande
maintien du salaire réel depuis deux ans
et encore je ne compte pas le pouvoir
d'achat qui a été perdu depuis 10 ans
puisqu'à chaque fois les hausses de
salaire n'ont aussi les qu'entre 0 et
0,3% alors que la hausse des prix était
autour de 1%. merci merci
Monsieur div merci Monsieur Présidente
je vais un peu dénoter t'a parlé de
coupure d'électricité ou de problèmes de
réseau simplement me référer l'actualité
hier aujourd'hui nous apprenons qu'il y
a des mouvements de grève dans plusieurs
centres enedis en France dans le Rhône
Bologne sur Mer dans dans leur et Cher
etc et je fais appel à votre passé
d'expérience de DRH dans un autre grand
groupe pour avoir une réponse non pas
sur les suites qui seront données
individus par individus mais plutôt pour
nous rassurer sur le fait qu'on ne se
heurte pas dans quelques semaines à des
situations de blocage pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens comme on l'a pu vivre il
y a maintenant quelques semaines dans un
autre secteur
merci beaucoup monsieur boulot
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente je voudrais revenir sur vos
propos liminaire vous nous avez indiqué
deux choses la première évidemment nous
rappelant le rôle de la péricotion les
réseaux et de la solidarité territoriale
et puis inversement nous disons que vous
appuyez le développement de
l'autoconsommation collective et donc
j'aimerais vous interroger sur les
limites de cette auto-consommation qui
fait actuellement l'objet d'un grand
intérêt alors que les prix de l'énergie
de notamment de l'électricité augmente
et que certains territoires peuvent
s'appuyer sur des potentiels de
développement de production et de
production électrique loco donc quels
sont les limites de cette
autoconsommation quand elle dans quelle
limite elle est-elle bonne dans quelle
limite ne l'était plus quoi
merci Madame bateau
merci monsieur le Président de deux
questions la première c'est sur la
sobriété ou sur la décroissance de la
consommation d'électricité est-ce
Kennedy
porte des projets dans ce domaine on se
souvient que sur le compteur Linky les
gouvernements successifs n'ont
malheureusement pas retenu la
proposition d'avoir un afficheur déporté
qui permettrait aux gens d'avoir en
permanence le suivi en fait de leur
consommation voilà donc est-ce que vous
avez des projets dans ce domaine
deuxième question qui est la résilience
du réseau de distribution aux événements
climatiques extrêmes
qui s'accumule et qui s'aggravent donc
je voulais savoir si le format de la
force d'intervention rapide
d'enedis qui est bien connu de tous les
Français notamment de celles et ceux qui
peuvent être confrontés à ces événements
et qui voient les équipes intervenir
pour rétablir l'électricité est-ce que
le format actuel de cette force est
suffisant et ma deuxième question très
brièvement monsieur le Président c'est
les câbles à papier imprégnés c'est à
dire qu'on a avec les très fortes vagues
de chaleur et les canicules extrêmes une
fonte en fait de l'isolant de ces de ces
vieux système de câbles est-ce que on a
une proportion de ce que ça représente à
l'échelle nationale et du risque que
cela représente pour le réseau de
distribution d'électricité merci
beaucoup monsieur bonjour
monsieur le Président Madame ma
présidente moi je voudrais revenir sur
les réseaux on avait aujourd'hui on va
dire un réseau construit par rapport à
des lieux production qui était pas très
importants on va dire à l'échelle de
nationale et aujourd'hui bien sûr avec
le développement des productions variées
moi je m'interroge puisque j'ai quelques
exemples qui dernièrement sur des des
grosses fermes agricoles en
photovoltaïque dans des milieux donc
dans le milieu rural dans des dans des
hameaux et où le réseau n'étant pas
construit visiblement pour absorber ces
productions il y a des on constate des
problèmes dans le voisinage dans les
habitations à proximité je voulais
savoir si si c'est des éléments que vous
aviez ou pas puisque quand on parle
quand même que le compteur Linky qui qui
grille deux ou trois fois dans l'année
et avec des dégâts donc voilà je je bon
c'est peut-être marginal mais je me dis
que pour l'avenir est-ce que c'est des
remontées que vous avez merci
merci
madame Baptiste
oui merci monsieur le Président quelques
minutes comme madame la Présidente n'a
pas pu répondre à la question de son
degré d'information sur les nouveaux
projets Hercule bis ou bis 2 ou bistroi
et les inquiétudes que ça pouvait
susciter je préfère le rappeler pour
qu'elle n'oublie pas dans sa dans sa
conclusion
monsieur l'aîné merci monsieur le
Président c'est un nouveau une question
sur le volet social de l'entreprise
puisque nous croyons savoir que les
salariés sont visiblement recrutés en
dessous du SMIC soit 1329 euros net par
mois donc comment est-ce que on peut
expliquer cela par ailleurs les salariés
qui sont en grève actuellement faut état
d'une perte de sens de leur travail
alors ici nous ne sommes pas des
porte-paroles syndicaux évidemment nous
sommes des députés de la nation mais il
en va du bon fonctionnement d'un service
public si on est mal payé si on perd du
sens au travail et bien on va se
retrouver à unedis comme c'est le cas
dans l'éducation nationale comme c'est
le cas dans les hôpitaux à courir après
des gens qui vont pas avoir envie de
travailler pour gagner des clopinettes
ou pas trouver de sens à leur travail
donc voilà on se permet de poser ces
questions sur le volet social merci
oui simplement pour redire si que la
question de la distribution est quand
même assez clé que effectivement dans
Métropole a signé un contrat de
transition énergétique dans ce sens mais
je faisais référence au contrat de
concession et si on a un rapport actuel
de ce que fait enedis on n'a pas de
négociation ou de pouvoir c'est-à-dire
quand ma collègue Delphine bateau évoque
les papiers imprégnés sur la disparition
le renouvellement des réseaux on n'a pas
de possibilités d'intervention sur ce
sujet là et c'est ça que je soulevais
ensuite localement également nous avons
travaillé avec enedis sur des plans de
recrutement puisque enedis en région
nous faisait part de la difficulté de
recrutement dans un certain nombre de
métiers et qui pour la prévision et la
mise en oeuvre et l'évolution du réseau
qui va connaître une révolution
importante et effectivement un problème
donc est-ce que vous avez un plan de
recrutement et de formation des équipes
puisque on manque de personnel pour
mettre en œuvre la transition
énergétique
merci monsieur le Président comme
d'autres collègues moi je m'interroge
sur la mission désormais d'enedis dans
un système où est promu l'autoproduction
l'autoconsommation et où la dispersion
des producteurs même si le produit pour
le réseau va être une nouvelle
difficulté est-ce que vous avez eu un
chiffrage un travail d'anticipation pour
mesurer le surcoût pour enedis ou le
coup générer en tout cas par année 10
par cette nouvelle donne de la
libéralisation et de la dispersion de la
production d'énergie et d'autre part
dans les procédures qui s'élaborent dans
la loi avez-vous été associés et est-il
envisagé vous soyez associé comme RTE à
la définition des zones pertinentes pour
la protection de NR pour obtenir le mix
énergétique
bien est-ce qu'il y a madame peut-être
oui vraiment rapidement et c'est une
question qui est en fait une question de
nos collègues qui ne peut pas être là
vous avez parlé très très rapidement
tout à l'heure de
de votre enfin en tout cas de la
permanence de du réseau pour les acteurs
de télécommunication qui dispose eux
d'une autonomie de 30 minutes mais
qui au-delà vont connaître des problèmes
s'il y a des délaissages s'il y a des
coupures sur le réseau
nous n'avons pas très bien compris tout
à l'heure comment vous allez pouvoir
résoudre ce problème là puisque eux ont
quand même une une obligation de service
public dans la transmission des
communications
merci je crois que je n'ai plus de
questions donc très bien voilà la
Présidente je vous propose de répondre
si on peut ramasser les réponses en une
dizaine de minutes ce serait vraiment
parfait
quinzaine maximum et bien parfait 15
minutes ce serait vraiment génial voilà
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci pour
toutes ces questions qui touchent aux
différentes activités vous voyez la
diversité des questions la diversité de
la nature de nos activités donc elle
peut rénover est un dispositif que nous
testons dans le dans le Calvados qui
permet d'utiliser les données globales
produites par les compteurs Linky pas
les donner individuels mais globaliser
pour donner des pistes d'économie
d'énergie aux différentes collectivités
et c'est une aussi une question de
Madame bateau ça fait partie de notre
effort de soviétoriété nous venons
d'ouvrir un portail pour l'ensemble des
collectivités locales qui a un grand
succès puisque ça leur met des tableaux
de bord des alertes sur leur
consommation à disposition et donc ils
peuvent eux-mêmes exploiter ces données
qui sont un peu
arides quand elles ne sont que brutes
mais là nous les accompagnons dans le
pilotage de leur éclairage public pour
faire des économies du chauffage de leur
bâtiment et ce grâce au compteur Linky
donc nous allons c'est aussi en lien
avec les PIMS puisque ça fait partie
aussi de solidarité
nous allons déployer de manière plus
industrielle les solutions qui sont les
plus pertinentes pour les collectivités
nous en testons plus que nous n'en
déployons de manière industrielle parce
que l'innovation c'est aussi
l'expérimentation j'ai eu beaucoup de
questions sur les aspects sociaux et
donc je souhaiterais y répondre donc
effectivement en ce moment se déroule
des négociations salariales c'est la
troisième
round de négociation ce qui prouve qu'il
y a un véritable dialogue social je
voudrais rappeler ce que nous avons
proposé donc j'ignore date si ça a été
accepté puisque les négociations sont en
cours nous avions fait l'année dernière
une augmentation de 3,3% pour l'année
2022 nous proposons aujourd'hui une
augmentation moyenne des salaires de
8,85% pour 2023 donc vous voyez que les
deux additionnés couvrent largement
l'inflation or par énergie puisque notre
permettons d'enlever la part énergie de
l'inflation étant donné la situation des
salariés d'inites par rapport
au tarif agent donc qui s'élève à un peu
plus de 8% nous sommes largement au-delà
de 11%. ces augmentations sont
d'ailleurs complétées par des primes une
prime qui a déjà été versée en 2022 de
600 euros pour tous et une prime qui est
proposée en 2023 avec un plafond de 1135
euros par salarié donc ce sont des
propositions ambitieuses mais qui
reconnaissent aussi qu'il y a une
inflation réelle qui touche aussi les
salariés de la distribution qui sont des
salariés très engagés dans leur travail
je tiens à le dire puisque ça a été posé
comme question fier de travailler à
enedis et donc il rentre pas de
démotivation au contraire nous avons un
très fort taux d'engagement et de fierté
d'appartenance à l'entreprise c'est
assez normal pour une entreprise qui
pratique l'ascenseur social un cadre sur
deux n'étaient pas cadre en entrant à
enedis c'est 15% chez Renault c'est 50 %
chez enedis donc nous mettons en œuvre
l'ascenseur social de l'exécution vers
la maîtrise de la maîtrise vers
l'encadrement avec 7% de la masse
salariale consacrée à la formation je
reviens sur les salaires puisque vous
avez parlé d'embauché en dessous du SMIC
c'est totalement inexact et dans le
passé je viens de parler de l'avenir
mais dans le passé les salariés et
inédits sont bénéficiés d'une
augmentation d'environ 30% de salaire
pour la période 2010 à 2021 comparé une
inflation d'environ 13% sur la même
période j'ai dit tout à l'heure que nous
recrutions alors effectivement merci de
le rappeler nos difficultés elles
tiennent à notre capacité à sur des
métiers techniques
dont malheureusement la tractivité n'est
pas toujours au top et on ne peut que le
déplorer nous cherchons des salariés
bac+2 Electrotech sur les métiers de
l'électricité et si je prends que
l'exemple des Pays de Loire vous
connaissez bien et bien il y a 300
apprentis qui rentrent dans les
formations d'apprentissage disponibles
sur le territoire il y en a à peu près
50 qui n'ont pas leur diplôme il y en a
100 qui continuent à travailler et il y
en a déjà 50 qui sont en apprentissage
dans les entreprises donc il alors que
sa sature déjà totalement les seuls
besoins nédis en termes de recrutement
sans parler de l'ensemble de nos
prestataires avec qui nous travaillons
donc oui nous allons lancer un grand
projet avec l'ensemble de nos
partenaires autour des écoles des
métiers des réseaux de l'électricité
pour redonner de l'attractivité ça sert
à rien de tous essayer de recruter sur
un périmètre défini trop petit il faut
élargir ce périmètre et encourager les
jeunes y compris les jeunes femmes à
rejoindre des métiers techniques qui
sont des métiers de la transition
écologique vous pouvez compter sur nous
là dessus
la résilience face aux situations
extrêmes la firent la force
d'intervention rapide de l'électricité
qui a été mise en place après la grande
tempête Klaus de 1999 tout le monde s'en
souvient quand aujourd'hui 2000 salariés
nous les mobilisons dans un temps
extrêmement rapide et même grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle combinée aux
algorithmes météo nous pouvons prévoir
les endroits où le réseau risque d'être
endommagés en cas de tempête avec le
vent qui souffle à 104 km de face sur
les côtes bretonne et nous envoyons en
avance nos équipes pour dépanner le plus
vite possible les clients la péréquation
n'est pas incompatible avec
l'autoconsommation l'autoconsommation ne
doit pas s'accompagner de tarifs
particuliers totalement réduit au
périmètre qu'on envisage parce que les
autoconsommateurs ont besoin du réseau
quand il consomme et quand il produisent
on a besoin si je puis dire doublement
et notamment en particulier quand il y a
pas de production solaire la nuit et
bien le réseau est là à disposition donc
il faut bien garder cela à l'esprit vous
avez raison quand on parle
d'autoconsommation ça n'est pas à la
place des investissements dans le réseau
donc oui nous sommes fortement engagés
dans des actions de sobriété que nous
prenons au sens du GIEC d'ailleurs sur
les quatre les quatre dimensions pas
seulement au sens de l'énergie donc ça
ne conduit à travailler de plus en plus
sur la biodiversité sur la ressource en
eau sur les matériaux et sur les
minerais rares et d'ailleurs nos
salariés nous les avons sollicités pour
qu'ils nous fassent des propositions en
termes de sobriété voilà ce que fait
l'entreprise qu'est-ce qu'elle pourrait
faire de plus de mieux de différents la
consultation est en cours elle dure
plusieurs
semaine des questions de nouveau autour
des télécoms donc les télécoms assurent
des missions de service public ils ont
des obligations de continuité de service
public et donc d'investir aussi pour la
garantir la continuité de ce service
public et notamment de s'équiper en
moyenne de secours en cas de défaillance
du réseau nous avons énormément
travaillé avec eux pour faire coïncider
les points critiques de leur réseau et
les points priorés classés prioritaires
par les préfets et ainsi
assuré pardon la résilience maximum des
réseaux télécoms notamment pour tous les
services d'urgence ce travail est en
cours il se fait entre deux opérateurs
chargés de mission essentielles de
services publics
dans les autres questions qui m'ont été
posées je finis évidemment par Hercule
pour vous dire
comment est-ce qu'il me paraît important
pour la distribution enedis représente à
peu près 25% du groupe EDF EN 25% de ces
salariés 25% de ses investissements 25%
de ses revenus c'est évidemment ce sont
sa dimension de service public et de
proximité on en a beaucoup parlé cet
après-midi donc plus que des questions
d'organisation et je n'ai pas conscience
ou connaissance de schémas préconçu
d'organisation j'ai écouté les propos du
ministre de l'économie assurant que on
ne commencerait pas par un projet
d'organisation ainsi que du futur
président d'EDF ce qui est important
pour la distribution c'est tout ce dont
nous avons parlé cet après-midi être une
grande entreprise de services publics et
donc tout à l'heure notre député du côté
élégie à parler de monopole nous sommes
déjà un monopole de ce fait mais un
monopole efficace et performant une
grande entreprise de service public avec
des missions dans la transition
écologique en croissance un haut niveau
d'investissement dans un modèle qui est
à la fois national et local avec la
péréquation et les collectivités locales
propriétaires des réseaux dans un groupe
le plus intégré possible parce que je
crois beaucoup caractère intégré du
groupe EDF ça me paraît tout à fait
essentiel pour la distribution et dans
un projet qui soit porteur de sens et
d'ambition et de fierté pour l'ensemble
des salariés de la distribution et c'est
ça qui est le plus important pour moi
que tout schéma d'organisation qui
serait déterminée à l'avance et enfin
oui nous avons un ambition programme
pardon de d'éradication des câbles CPI
les plus
propre à générer des incidents et ça
fait partie des 96 milliards
d'investissements que j'ai indiqué être
nécessaire à l'horizon 2040 je crois que
je suis arrivée au terme
de mes minutes mais que j'ai essayé de
couvrir je pense avoir oublié l'ensemble
des questions vous aviez évoqué des
questions plutôt de milieu rural et donc
ces sujets à la fois de raccordement de
NR d'autoconsommation sont aussi la
réalité des territoires en ruraux ça
n'est pas ce ne sont pas des sujets
métropolitains ou urbains ce sont aussi
des sujets ruraux par exemple nous avons
accompagné l'élargissement de la
distance entre des fermes pour qu'elles
soient considérées à l'intérieur d'un
unique projet d'autoconsommation
collective à la réglementation a été
changée il y a pas longtemps pour que
des distances plus importantes puissent
cette prise en compte et donc nous
accompagnons l'ensemble de ces projets
bien sûr nous sommes très sensibles aux
éventuels problèmes de qualité de
l'électricité que vous pourriez nous
signaler mais comme je vous l'ai dit la
disponibilité du réseau est à 9
99 tout à fait excellente
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente pour
votre disponibilité et la qualité de vos
réponses merci chers collègues et je
vous propose de nous retrouver demain
9h30 pour l'examen du rapport
d'application de la loi assurance
emprunteur d'une part et puis nous
aurons une table ronde sur l'éolien en
mer et le photovoltaïque dans le cadre
du PJL ENR je vous remercie je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée